For O'Brien, becoming one of the North Shore's leading water men...
...is a story that's already in the making.
Victory at Pipe would cement that reputation.
Off here in Hawaii, we concentrate on surfing Pipeline, that's our everything.
It's like you're born right into it, you don't have a choice.
For now, Rothman seems content as an up-and-coming surfer...
...setting a new standard for youngsters and waves of consequence.
Many of his peers expect big things of him when the contest gets going.
I feel like I have a good understanding of Pipe, I would love to win.
As for Lau, it's not that long since he had to make a tough decision...
...about his sporting future.
Like all life choices, the conclusion lies ahead, not yet known.
But if Lau has his way, it's a future of life on the world tour,...
...the ultimate dream for most pro surfers.
When it comes game day, you gotta be willing to perform.
You gotta love the struggle, you gotta love every part of it.
You gotta love the good and the bad.